I'm gonna win this time you're not you
can't win playing arts out the engineers
do cuz I probably beat ya again whatever
I'm bored now
they're always born everything to
entertain you Christina and you take me
I want to watch anime don't watch anime
again okay
yes let's watch anime
cute girls and skirts and a boy that
wants to hold my hand let's watch this
one there are like this one yes go get
in
oh we will actually I don't have to get
up at all
oh right yeah we don't have to we're
gonna watch anime without putting this
in oh and do you know how no tell me how
well crunchyroll has a new ps3 up it's
done it does it does we can watch all
the anime walk from the comfort of these
seats up smokey and Totoro that's
awesome it is awesome you just login
with my username and a wild puppy
appears do you want to watch some anime
you must have play basic PlayStation 3
skills - this app you're so good at that
I've practiced for many new year logging
in we're gonna watch anime cool but
that's you haven't heard of the death
before and you haven't been able to play
around
did you want to go ahead and play around
look around here let's see what you're
watching oh gosh there's my cue oh yeah
Katzie I want to actually don't want to
see your cue okay I want to see
something you can actually pit press the
triangle button go to main menu I have
been acknowledged of shapes anime
awesome popular ooh this looks pretty
cool
I want to see on see this one because it
looks like it's an entire cast of
puppies okay go ahead and just hit enter
there you can pick an episode let's
start at the end okay
yeah well already love it doesn't know
there's no [ __ ]
not even a little circle things no
apricot
oh just gonna get everybody for watching
dog dicks so yeah we're watching it
right now you did it
don't you think this app will come in
handy later it will you're gonna watch
all the things launch every single
animal from the comfort of your couch
yes Christina thank you for playing